[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the breakthrough evidence that led to
the arrest of the accused killers of
college student
kristin smart presumed raped murdered
and seemingly vanished
we're talking about a case that's a cold
case for the past 25 years
and robert durst's defense expert faces
day two of cross-examination
our legal analysis leading up to the
highly anticipated testimony from the
real estate air himself
is it your desire today not to testify
on your own behalf
yes sir the fate of an accused cop
killer now in the hands of a jury
did stephen wiggins knowingly shoot
sergeant daniel baker then
set his body on fire ten shots fired
plus a florida sheriff's harsh words for
suspects busted in an undercover sting
for targeting children online
these are nasty nasty nasty people
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer terry austin is off
today
a 12-day long hearing is underway in the
christian smart case
where a judge will determine whether
there's enough evidence for a man
and his father to stand trial in her
death law and crime's angenette levy is
here with what's happened so far
antoinette brian paul flores is charged
with murdering kristin smart his father
reuben
is charged with being an accessory after
the fact
kristen smart was a 19 year old cal poly
student when she vanished on may 24th
1996. investigators have said paul
flores was walking smart
back to campus from a party and either
raped or tried to rape her before
killing her in his dorm room
a detective testified he interviewed
flores three days after kristen
disappeared
and he had a black eye they've never
deviated
from you know this narrative that flores
is the prom suspect in this forensic
death investigator joseph scott morgan
has followed the case
kristen smart's mother testified at the
hearing in california
saying her daughter wasn't particularly
happy at cal poly
but had sounded more optimistic before
she disappeared
denise smart called kristen the best
hugger and said she didn't have the
financial means to leave on her own
attorneys for paul flores and his father
reuben suggested smart
might have wanted to leave the country
there's no indication that
she had done that i think that again
this is just
a ploy on the part of the defense to
raise that specter of reasonable doubt
smart's remains have never been found
homes owned by the flores's have been
searched
and investigators have said they
believed that smart had been buried
at the home of ruben flores and the
remains recently moved
what's very fascinating about this case
is that the police have stated
that they do have physical evidence now
what
the nature of that physical evidence is
uh
is still in question now there's also
been some testimony that paul flores had
a nickname on campus
it was chester the molester and police
questioned him about that back then
when kristen smart first disappeared
there are women who also say they've had
violent sexual experiences with paul
flores they are also expected to testify
during this hearing
as well brian joining us today is judge
susan chris and criminal defense
attorney mike corebotix
just chris it's a preliminary hearing
meaning we aren't talking about proof
beyond a reasonable doubt
so what kind of facts would a judge be
looking at to push this case forward
well it really kind of depends on what
the evidence your issues are
are they sure is one side trying to
suppress things
completely or they're trying just to
subject to emotion and lemony which
means you have to approach the judge
first
so i mean as every lawyer says it
depends
it really depends and it depends upon
the facts but you want to make sure that
it's relevant that it's it's it's
material it's primitive and it's not
so probative that it's just prejudicial
it makes perfect sense now mike with
some of these facts no body a mysterious
disappearance
and this physical evidence that
prosecution says they have but at least
the public hasn't seen
what's the defense's strategy here
well it's going to be very interesting
to see what the defensive strategy is
we've been seeing a
trend more and more about these cold
cases that are being tried
10 15 years later than actually when
they occurred
and these are very very careful and i
think the prosecutors need to be more
careful quite frankly
on than the defense right here because
you've got to watch that you don't over
overdue
your evidence you're putting in to make
up for the lack of evidence you may have
absolutely no angeannet convicted
murderer scott peterson was brought up
at one point during the hearing
how's he connected to all this well
if you ask police they say he's not and
the prosecutors say he isn't either
scott peterson of course convicted of
murdering his wife lacey and their
unborn son
um connor they went missing on christmas
eve at 2002.
peterson is currently serving um time in
prison
for those two murders he was a student
at cal poly at the time
and there's been a lot of discussion
over the years that he was at the party
lacey peterson also went to cal poly too
and that he was at the party where
kristen smart was present that night but
police and prosecutors say they have
investigated that and scott peterson is
not involved in kristen smart's murder
all right so you said the prosecution
kind of moving that suspect aside this
is a preliminary hearing one expected to
last
12 days we'll of course give you updates
as those begin thank you everyone
turning now to more top legal news a
florida sheriff has strong words
for 17 suspects including disney
employees arrested
in an undercover state the sheriff says
the suspects preyed upon children online
during operation child protector
but much to the chagrin instead of
meeting with
children young children they were met by
law enforcement officers from the police
departments as well as the sheriff's
office
who were online undercover
posing as children these are nasty
nasty nasty people
still ahead on law and crime daily a
jury deliberating the fate of a man
accused of shooting
and killing a deputy then lighting his
body on fire
but first inside the courtroom for the
robert durst trial the contentious
cross-examination of the defense's
expert witness continues into day two
the testimony you don't want to miss
[Music]
next
[Music]
welcome back robert durst attorneys are
continuing to put on their defense
in the trial of the real estate air
accused of murdering his best friend
susan berman
dr elizabeth loftus was back on the
stand for the second day of testimony on
thursday
she's a memory expert known for
consulting in high profile cases such as
harvey weinstein
bill cosby and ted bundy on direct she
suggested one of the state key witnesses
could have had a false memory about the
defendant allegedly confessing to the
murder
saying quote it was her or me i had no
choice
on cross prosecutor john lewin tried to
pick apart that assessment
how on earth could it be anything other
than extremely upsetting
if a close friend is now basically
saying
they helped cover up a murder
if if somebody believed the speaker was
it
had a tendency to exaggerate or even
um be dramatic and it might not be
upsetting
so what you're telling me it might just
be a story that's right so what you're
telling me is is that if the person
did not believe what they were told at
the time
then they might have less of a memory of
the event is that correct
well then they might not find it
particularly upsetting
this cross-examination has been
repeatedly interrupted with sidebars in
the judge's chambers
the defense objected after prosecutor
lewin asked the doctor
about using qualifiers to answer the
question
you asked me whether i used qualifiers
in my response to mr chesnov's question
and it's my recollection that i did
do you think you used the same or a
similar amount of qualifiers with mr
chesnuff as you're doing with me
i i i don't recall the exact answers
so doctor if somebody put a gun to your
head and said hey listen
you've got to get this answer right you
think you've used more qualifiers with
mr chesnov
or with me what would you say objection
yeah
that's just that's the argument i'm
trying to get an answer your honor
well no gun to the head is a
particularly
ugly metaphor and i'm not going to allow
you to insult the witness in this way
let's bring back our special guest judge
susan chris who presided over
robert durst's first murder trial in
texas for the death of his neighbor
morris black now your honor you've had a
front row seat to robert durst on the
witness stand
what should we anticipate his direct to
sound like in this case
you know he was very charming um in our
case but
in the meantime he said so many things
that he has to walk
back he has to walk back on the jinx
talking about
deceiving the jury and so he's going to
have to have a pretty clever story to do
that
but i'm sure it's going to be very
rehearsed they're going to have
something
they're going to have something and he's
going to he's going to put that forth
but
i can't imagine lewin not
cross-examining him
and undoing whatever they do on direct
all right so clever
charming rehearsed thank you very much
for that your honor now he may not be a
judge but he's honorable in my eyes
let's bring in criminal defense attorney
mike corrobonics
mike after the doctor's testimony
would you be advising duras to testify
or not
i don't think his attorneys are in a
position to advise the master anything
i think he's going to do what he wants
to do
and i think what he wants to do is he
wants to take the stand
and i think quite frankly louellan
sometimes
the prosecutor in this case sometimes
through other witnesses is prepping
durst for when he's going to
cross-examine him
by i think sort of like challenging him
let him know what to expect
that he's not going to be consistent in
the way he gets cross-examined
i think it's going to be very
interesting and very very much
worth the watch and absolutely don't
forget that a
criminal defendant has the absolute
right to testify a lawyer can only
advise them
and at the end of the day it's their
choice i think the judge would agree
he's probably going to make that choice
now judge you remember the black trial
better than anyone else
when you think of the testimony in susan
berman's trial do you think any of the
witnesses had any memory issues
i don't think a single one did when it
comes to the substance of their
testimony
i think the jinx made it possible for
them to
admit that they knew things but they
didn't remember because they were
watching it
or seeing something in the newspaper you
don't have someone tell you
that they alive for somebody during a
murder
or they commit you don't forget a word
of that
ever that's ridiculous yeah mike
corbonis what do you think about that
the way
memory imprints do you think that this
is something that someone would be like
i don't know mike corbonix told me about
this murder that he had years ago i'm
gonna forget about it do you think
that's
realistic here no i don't but i think
that's the only one of the only avenues
they could travel since it's such an old
case
if they didn't put on a witness about
memory i think they'd be
having to worry about an ineffective
assistance to the council client
absolutely so it makes sense maybe this
is more of a strategy
in that this is so long ago people could
have had
uh memory issues they could have maybe
misremembered they could have maybe
thought he said x instead of y or z so
maybe this is just
good litigation where maybe the facts
don't rest on your side which makes a
lot of sense in this
the california versus robert durst case
don't forget to check it out we've got
it on law and crime network for capital
capital coverage
thank you both coming up on law and
crime daily hear from stephen wiggins
himself
days after he's accused of shooting a
sheriff's deputy in the head
his shocking admission to investigators
after the break
welcome back we head to tennessee where
a jury has reached a verdict for the
fate of a man accused of shooting a
deputy
and lighting his body on fire
wiggins is charged with first-degree
murder vehicular arson and abuse of a
corpse for the death of dickinson county
sheriff's deputy
sergeant daniel baker if convicted
wiggins can face the death penalty
baker was killed on may 28 2018 two days
later
investigators caught wiggins he agreed
to sit down for an interview and
admitted to the shooting
wigan says he tried to give cpr to baker
but when he realized baker didn't have a
pulse
he fired another round because quote
it's like a dog you don't let it suffer
i don't know
[Music]
everybody was like
[Music]
[Music]
just in case
[Music]
the trial nearly came to a halt after
prosecutors played a portion of the
defendant's police interrogation
when he talked about selling drugs that
the judge already ruled the jury
couldn't hear
the judge denied the mistrial request
and the court resumed
here's the clip but listen jimmy i
hear you say that but i've heard you
two times i know for sure maybe three
times
but you've told us the gun was way
underneath the scene
whenever he pulled up but but he hit it
up under my seat whenever he pulled up i
kicked it as hard as i could his part
under my seat
why was it out
when we come back the defendant's
decision on whether or not to take the
stand in his own defense
plus closing army arguments which side
will the jury believe
the verdict ahead
back now to the trial of the accused cop
killer stephen wiggins
prosecutors rested and the defense asked
their client that all-important question
will he take the stand in his own
defense
mr wiggins have i along with mr simmons
and mr hopkins
fully explained to you you're right
absolute right to testify on your own
behalf in this trial
yes sir likewise have the three of us
also
fully explain to your right
not to have to testify to ever have to
testify in this trial
yes sir and do you understand those
rights
just sir and understanding those rights
and having talked about that
is it your desire today not to testify
on your own behalf
yes sir with that the defense rested
without calling any witnesses and court
proceeded to closing arguments
prosecutors say the defendant knew he
was going to kill an officer
if he was stopped and purposely tried to
cover up the evidence
19 stephen wiggins the defendant
took the life of dixon county sheriff's
deputy sergeant daniel baker
when he murdered him by methodically
shooting
sergeant daniel baker six times
and the voice that you all heard on
there was the defendant stephen wiggins
impersonating sergeant daniel baker
the officer and the floorboard or the
back seat
of his car and he was acting in a law
enforcement capacity
impersonating a law enforcement officer
calling in with those codes registering
those things
the defense admits wiggins killed baker
but says the shooting wasn't
premeditated
and asked the jury to consider the
charge of second-degree murder
we're not asking you to not hold mr
wiggins responsible for the killing
that's not what i'm standing here doing
and that's what we told you at the
beginning of this trial we were not here
to say
he didn't kill him and that sergeant
baker is not a victim
we're asking you to consider the law
and the law requires that as angry as
you may be as
biased as you may now be that you not
allow those emotions in and you'll get
instructions on that
your decision has to be done with
reflection and judgment
you have to also have those emotions put
to the side
so that you do what's right
not what's just vengeful on rebuttal
prosecutors reminded the jury of
sergeant baker's last words
shots fired officer down
why did sergeant baker need to give that
warning
because the defendant
was able to fool sergeant baker
once how
did he manipulate and fool sergeant
baker
by using his reflection and judgment
he was able to convince sergeant baker
to stop the felony encounter
to reholster his weapon and allow
the defendant to exit that vehicle
through the passenger side
that takes an exercise
of reflection and judgment
after just 90 minutes of deliberation
the jury reached a verdict
here's their decision
as to count one of the indictment the
charge of false report
can you tell me how does the ver how
does the jury find
guilty as to count two
premeditated first degree murder how
does the jury find
guilty as to felony murder of
first degree murder felony murder on
count three how did the jury
fund guilty your honor
judge chris your thoughts on the verdict
but also the speed in which the jury
decided
i'm not surprised i was expecting a
guilty verdict and the trial
i was surprised the trial was so fast
but with the evidence being what it was
the emotional
the cold-bloodedness of it i was not
surprised that they got a quit guilty
yeah the defense really tried to narrow
in on an argument and i respect him for
that especially based on the facts going
for
just premeditation but i don't think the
facts reflected that argument and i
think the jury came back pretty quickly
and pretty precisely
in that now mike the penalty phase
begins saturday
the defense couldn't charm the top count
away because they were just asking to
beat that and only that not the other
charges
do you think there is any luck in maybe
charming away the death penalty here
i think i always think someone that has
a shot of doing that
and it's a possibility because i always
think there are some jurors who have
strong reservations about the death
penalty
even though they try to be as fair as
possible i think this defense
did a very good job of really starting
to charm that away
for the penalty phase during the trial
phase and i think they've maintained
credibility
and i think the confession is going to
be a big play
in the penalty phase because this is the
first time in that
where the actual there's a showing of
remorse by the defendant
absolutely now real quick let's ask
judge chris uh
we haven't heard the penalty phases yet
but what do you think death penalty or
life without the possibility of parole
what would you guess
i'm gonna guess death penalty but i i do
agree
that you know it's one thing to say i'm
for the death penalty
it's a whole other thing to issue a
verdict that results in someone
being executed but i think the facts
here are so strong
a death penalty is not going to surprise
me yeah mike we've seen the country kind
of change a little bit over the time
after the response to the death penalty
but a case like this what do you think
death penalty or life without the
possibility of parole
my my feeling is they're going to come
back with the death penalty based on the
facts of this case
i would tent to agree as well of course
if you stay with law and crime network
to see what the result is
thank you both and thank you for joining
us here at law on crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you